on essaie aussi de faire comme les
joueurs comme les professionnels n'ont
connu sommes amateurs
soudaineté mettre au niveau
[Musique]
parce que là parce que le même style de
jeu comme messi se marre qui joue du
pied droit et il me plaît beaucoup mater
on la sait à 18 des tables c'est chez
lui qu'il y apprend beaucoup et il ya
aussi franck teyssier les mutins de la
côte d'ivoire naby keita est l'un des
modèles j'adore beaucoup son jeu sa
récupération de balle et sa façon de se
déplacer dans l'heure de jeu prochain au
coup de sifflet temps seconde
accélération
quand je le vois sur l'air de jeu ça me
pousse ça me motive à travailler plus ou
essayer d'arriver à ce niveau là c'est
un rêve pour nous aussi d'arriver à ce
niveau là c'est
époustouflant de leurs voisins le rêve
chaque fois que l'on a ça me dit que
j'ai pu aussi arriver comme si un jour
garde espoir sait jamais combien de
joueurs professionnels comme tous les
autres footballeur mon rêve c'est de
jouer aussi et que le plus barré
peut-être même ronaldinho
c'est mon rêve depuis que j'allais à 3
ans et veut que ça se réalise
nous sommes des jeunes étudiants des
jeunes techniciens du coup on a choisi
chaque mardi soir pas se la joue et
garder la forme et à la joue et qui
s'identifient aux jeux de la gamme
exemple le juglar le but j'essaye de
vous faire les mêmes choses je suis venu
ici juste pour les la servent les années
puisque de temps en temps ce degré sur
le corps on y met des limites sans
limites ni mêlée sur le super star on
vit ici mais à cet âge tu peux pas faire
plus court puisque tu fais leurs genoux
[Musique]